Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
So, abhängig.
müsste ich habe die falschen egal ich habe die falschen socken noch an
wurscht
stellenanzeigen wird heute leider nichts das ist zu kurz von der zeit her weiß
nicht wie lange ich heute zeit habe aber ich muss noch ein paar sachen einkaufen
Das können wir zusammen machen.
Aber vorher,
jetzt kann ich nochmal hier
Mini-PC anschmeißen.
Lass wir da drüber gleich...
Das muss aufbleiben, das muss so, das muss so,
das muss so, das muss zack.
Und jetzt machen wir an.
es war doch eine gute idee dass ich diese pc express elgato gekauft habe das ding ist
echt nah ist das funkt auch viel besser als dieses usb teil was ich hatte so gut
wie keine latency 240 hertz also sehr ob hoge nicht zu sagen
POG U.
Was geht?
Bison Bumsli.
Geiler Name.
Ich habe schon wieder Steam anstatt Stream geschrieben.
Ob du noch mit jemandem von früher...
Äh, mit dem Fabian ab und zu mal...
Aber es gibt halt gerade wenig Spieleüberschneidung.
Aber sobald es da wieder was gibt, denke ich,
kann das durchaus sein, dass wir hier nochmal
zusammen auftauchen irgendwann.
Könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Äh, Chat.
Chat.
Was macht meine Logi...
Was macht diese Logitech-Software?
Warum spackt die hier gerade rum?
Logitech, geh hopp!
Microsoft Creation
Moment, Moment, Moment
Ist das nicht jetzt endgültig dead?
Im Leben hätten wir nicht so ein Scammer-Game gespielt
Logitech G-Hub wird nochmal in Rust geschrieben
Ganz im Ernst
Der alte Logitech Maustreiber
Der war natürlich nicht so hübsch wie das hier
Und Chat, Chat, wollen wir wetten, das hier ist eigentlich nur ein Browser.
Das ist bestimmt einfach auch wieder so ein Embedded Chrome oder Elektronen-Geschiss hier.
100 Pro, das ist einfach ein Browser.
Das sieht man schon, guckt euch mal an.
Das sieht man schon, wie die Ecken, wie diese runden Ecken gerendert werden, dass das Browser und CSS gedöhnt ist.
Theoretisch
müssten die ja auch
ähm
hier teilweise schreiben, was sie für
Source-Sachen verwendet haben.
Das ist bestimmt Elektron. Könnte ich wetten.
Der alte Logitech-Treiber, der war zwar
hässlich, aber da konntest du
Lua-Skripts und sowas drinnen benutzen.
Ich glaube, das geht jetzt bei dem Neuen schon mal gar nicht.
Ein Prime-Abo.
Pog?
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Moment. Achso, deswegen gehen meine Emotes.
Ich habe das gar nicht gestartet.
Sekunde.
Jetzt aber.
Bisschen groß die Emotes vielleicht gerade.
So.
Wir verbinden!
So, das ist vorbei.
Das haben wir geschafft.
Guck mal,
wie man den
groß
faken kann hier.
Oh, jetzt nass, Leute.
Was
glaubt ihr denn,
wie viel Bedarf
habe ich noch für eine Nass, wenn ich
gerade schon drei Stück hier stehen habe.
Nochmal,
nochmal fünf.
Also, ich schicke eins davon ja auch wieder
zurück. Das andere ist leider schon abgelaufen,
vor der Rückschickfrist.
Genau.
Noch einen? Wieso? Ich habe doch drei.
Reicht doch für einen Cluster.
Amazon!
Leaked.
So, was will mir denn Amazon
hier wieder für ein ganzes... Was passiert
eigentlich? Wie gesagt, die Location stimmt
nicht ganz genau, aber so die Richtung.
Kann man das...
Kann man seinem Browser nicht...
Kann man seinem Browser nicht sagen...
Ach, der macht das anhand der Public-IP,
wo man angeblich ist, ne?
Alter.
Equate.
Roborock.
Update-Location, ja ganz bestimmt.
Noch mit Adresse und allem am besten, ne?
Roborock trendet
Top Deals
Das wollte ich eigentlich
gar nicht gucken
Aber können wir trotzdem mal
Ne, das ist ein Mova
Das ist ein Staubsauger
Ne, kein Staubsauger, ein Rasenmäheroboter
oder? Hier, Lawnmower
Hast du das mit dem
Äh
Ne, was ist das für eine Abkürzung
Ach ne, das ist der Hersteller der auch Drohnen baut
Oder
DJI
Ich hab erst gesagt du wolltest sagen do it yourself
Das ist eine andere Abkürzung
Ne, was ist da, das hab ich nicht mitgekriegt
Das ist eine Drohne die einen Staubsauger
drin hat oder was?
Alle gehackt.
Der ist immer wieder dabei,
dass ich keinen Bock habe auf irgendwelche Cloud-Dinger.
Guck mal. Moment, wie...
Wie heißt dieses Ding?
D-J-I-Staubsauger?
News.
Warte mal, Moment.
Tüftler erlangen Zugriff auf tausende Geräte und Live-Kameras.
Ja, deswegen muss nicht jeder Scheiß in die Cloud.
Leute, es macht überhaupt keinen Sinn, dass ein Staubsauger in der Cloud ist.
Okay, das nehme ich zurück.
Es kann in manchen Fällen sinnvoll sein,
Ja, wenn man zum Beispiel, you must enable DRM, ich kann auch einfach zuklicken, ja, wenn man von unterwegs das starten möchte oder sowas.
Wobei da halt auch die Frage, ist das wirklich relevant?
Weil man kann auch einfach ein Schedule anlegen.
Also ich bin ein ganz großer Fan davon, wenn die Geräte einen Modus ohne Cloud unterstützen.
Okay, vielleicht gibt es ein paar Zusatzfunktionen, die Cloud brauchen, aber dieses Default in die Cloud ist einfach so dumm.
Und es waren in den letzten paar Jahren so viele Hersteller, jetzt mal unabhängig von irgendwie Hacker-Man-Zeug,
die einfach pleite gegangen sind oder Produkte eingestellt haben und dann ging es nicht mehr, weil es nur über die Cloud läuft.
So ein Scheiß, ne?
Ich habe aber den Eindruck gehabt, gerade die letzten 1-2 Jahre geht der Trend bei vielem wieder weg von alles in die Cloud.
Die Leute haben es jetzt halt einfach gecheckt mit der Zeit.
Warte mal.
Ihr smarte Staubsaugerroboter
Sollten eigentlich eine Hilfe
Bla bla bla
Sicherheitsvorfall
Staubsaugerroboter
Semmy A. Stufal
Seines Zeichens Head of AI
Okay das ist Französisch
Keine Ahnung wie man das ausspricht
Bei der Französischen
Sodass er das Gadget auch mit einem PS5
Der wollte das so modifizieren
Dass er mit einem PS5 Controller steuern kann
um das zu erreichen hat er mit cloud code einen eine anwendung per reverse
engineering wie soll das funktionieren
er muss das ding schon irgendwie füttern du kannst schlecht sagen cloud code
reverse engineer mal bitte meinen staubsauger so einfach so das ganze
schon sagen, das wird nicht funktionieren.
Um auf den sogenannten Private Token
zuzugreifen zu können, an den umzugreifen...
Moment, der hat im Endeffekt
einen Wireshark gestartet und mitgeschnitten,
oder was?
Was ja durchaus geht,
wenn die es nicht richtig machen.
Also ich erinnere euch nochmal daran,
wir haben die Fiat App
auch mal etwas reverse-ingeniert
mit einem Man-in-the-Middle-Proxy
und damals haben wir dem Android,
auf dem die Fiat App lief,
ein
selbst signiertes
SSL-Zertifikat untergeschoben,
dass wir Man-in-the-Middle proxien können.
Also das könnte ich mir hier auch vorstellen.
Stand nur Zugriff auf seinen
eigenen Schlüssel und damit
seinen Staubsauger-Roboter zu bekommen, fand die App
tausende Geräte.
Aber wahrscheinlich war der Token
zu einfach zu erraten, oder?
Das vermute ich mal.
Der Token war wahrscheinlich easy zu erraten.
Ja.
Oh Mann.
Da haben halt wieder irgendwelche Kack-Noobs
Vibe-Coded.
Bei sowas.
Zudem kann...
Was? Schau mal, soll ich
Führerfahrten erstellen?
Live-Kamera-Bild von den Gadgets abzurufen.
Okay, der hat es gemeldet.
Innerhalb kürzester Zeit konnte der Hersteller
die Sicherheitslücke schließen.
Ich wette mit euch nicht sonderlich gut.
Heise hat dazu ein gutes Video gemacht.
Was wollen die hier jetzt?
Geh mal weg mit irgendwelchen komischen Videos.
Einfach random Videos stellst.
Heise hat dazu...
Okay.
Wo?
Du meinst auf YouTube oder bei heise.de?
Letzte Schule Berlins hat nun Glasfaser.
Und nun?
Naja, immerhin.
YouTube?
Ach guck mal, hier gibt es sogar den Link.
Ach, Moment mal, hier.
Chat.
Starten wir das mal wieder.
Kann ich mich trauen, das anzuklicken?
Ja, es ist YouTube.
Okay.
Ein Augroboter mit einem PS5-Controller steuern will
und dabei plötzlich Zugriff auf fremde Wohnzimmer bekommt,
das war kein Hacker
Sekunde, ich mach mal kurz die Musik aus
In Deutschland wird es mal wieder problematisch
dann ist es wahrscheinlich wieder
Hacker-Stelz und der wird verklagt
oder so
...komplexer Cyberangriff, sondern ein reales
Problem, das erst letzte
Woche aufgefallen ist. Und diesen Zugriff
erhielt der Entwickler nicht nur auf das Kamerabild
sondern auch auf den Grundriss der Wohnung und auf die Steuerung des Geräts selbst.
Heute schauen wir uns an, was da technisch genau schief gelaufen ist und warum schlecht
abgesicherte Smart Home Geräte für uns alle zum Risiko werden können.
Los geht's nach einer kurzen Werbepause.
Dieses Video wird unterstützt von Mammut.
Wer mit KI arbeitet, kennt das Problem.
Verklaut ein Abo für GPT, ein weiteres, für Bildgenerierung noch eins.
Das wird schnell teuer und unübersichtlich.
Genau hier setzt Mammut an.
Mammut bündelt die besten KI-Modelle an einem Ort. GPT, Claude, Mistral, Gemini, DeepSea, Perplexity,
Was die so alles machen.
Unterbilder Flux und NanoBanana. Das Starter-Paket kostet 11,99 Euro im Monat. Alle neuen Modellversionen
sind automatisch inklusive. Besonders praktisch die Reprompting-Funktion. Die vergleicht Antworten
verschiedener Modelle direkt. Ihr könnt eigene Assistenten mit spezifischen Anweisungen erstellen,
Deep Research über Perplexity nutzen, Dokumente und Bilder analysieren oder SVGs generieren. Mammut
ist ein europäisches Unternehmen mit Sitz in Paris. Die Daten werden DSGVO-konform gehostet. Die Modelle
werden nicht mit euren Daten trainiert und ihr könnt euren Verlauf jederzeit löschen. Wenn ihr
kai prozent ohne euch bei fünf verschiedenen diensten anzumelden schaut euch mal gut an
der link ist in der beschreibung vor einsteigen erstmal kurz zur einordnung saugroboter mit
kameras und app steuerung sind längst alltag modelle von robo rock eco wächst robot oder
eben dji verbinden sich mit dem internet damit ihr sie auch von unterwegs aus steuern könnt
das funktioniert über sogenannte cloud server also rechner des herstellers die zwischen eurem
smartphone und dem roboter vermitteln für diese kommunikation nutzen viele hersteller ein
ein Protokoll namens MQTT.
Das steht für Message Queuing
Telemetry. Ja, es gibt
sogar einen eigenen Service bei Amazon für
IoT-Geräte. Weiß nicht, ob die
Amazon verwenden. Vielleicht, die haben bestimmt
eigenen Krempel.
Stellt euch das wie ein digitales schwarzes Brett vor.
Geräte pinnen dort ihre Statusmeldungen
an und die App holt sie sich ab.
Ach, hat der irgendwie, konnte
irgendwie einen Listener bei dem Broker dann
registrieren, sodass er von anderen Sachen auch
was bekommt? Okay, gucken wir mal.
Schlank und schnell, ideal für kleine stromsparende Geräte.
Das große Aber, damit dieses System sicher ist, muss der Server streng kontrollieren, wer welche Nachrichten lesen darf.
Jedes Gerät braucht quasi seinen eigenen abgesperrten Bereich auf diesem schwarzen Brett.
Passiert das nicht, und hier wird es kritisch, kann theoretisch jeder, der einmal Zugang zum System hat, alle Nachrichten aller Geräte mitlesen.
Genau das ist bei DJI passiert.
Die Geschichte beginnt mit einem KI-Figler bei einem französischen Immobilienunternehmen und einem neuen DJI Romo, dem erst kürzlich vorgestellten Saugroboter von DJI.
DJI kennt man ja eigentlich eher als Drohnenhersteller.
Die Idee des Entwicklers, er wollte seinen Romo einfach mit einem PS5-Controller steuern, sowie ein Fernlenkauto.
Nichts Kriminelles, nur eine kleine Bastlerspielerei.
Um das hinzubekommen, hat er mithilfe des KI-Coding-Assistenten Cloud Code die DJI-App per Reverse Engineering analysiert.
Achso, jetzt verstehe ich das. Der hat die App runterladen lassen und hat gesagt, ey, find mal raus, was die eigentlich genau macht.
Um zu verstehen, wie sie mit den DJI-Servern spricht. Er wollte nur seinen eigenen Authentifizierungstoken extrahieren, also einen digitalen Schlüssel, der dem Server sagt, hey, das bin ich, ich darf auf meinen Roboter zugreifen.
Was dann passierte, war wohl auch für ihn ein Schock. Als seine selbstgebastelte App sich mit DJI Servern verband, antwortete nicht nur sein eigener Romo, sondern rund 7000 Geräte aus 24 Ländern.
Neun Minuten sammelte sein Laptop über 100.000 MQTT-Datenpakete. Er sah in Echtzeit Seriennummern der Geräte, welche Räume gerade gesaugt wurden, Hindernisse, Akkuladestatus, Grundrüste der Wohnungen.
Und er konnte live Kamerabilder abrufen. Vom Sofa in Barcelona aus war alles aufgestellt. Um das zu belegen, machte er einen Live-Test mit einem Journalisten des US-Tech-Portals The Verge.
Mit nur der Seriennummer des Roboters konnte er dessen Gerät in Washington Orton bestätigen, dass es gerade das Wohnzimmer bei 80% Akkustand saugt und einen detaillierten Grundriss der Wohnung generieren.
Das Problem lag nicht in der Verschlüsselung der Datenübertragung. DJI nutzt TLS, das ist die gleiche Verschlüsselung wie beim Online-Banking. Der Datentransport war also grundsätzlich abgesichert. Das Problem war ein Schritt weiter, auf dem NQTT-Server selbst. Konkret fehlten sogenannte Access Controls, kurz ACLs.
Also Zugriffslisten, die definieren, Nutzer A darf nur Gerät A sehen, Nutzer B nur Gerät B. Stattdessen konnte jeder authentifizierte Client, also jeder, der sich irgendwie mit einem gültigen Token einloggte, auf alle möglichen...